he is the most bankable star in
Hollywood an action hero with a massive
ripped physique who has impeccable
comedic timing and a never-ending supply
of charm he is also one of the greatest
wrestling superstars to ever emerge from
the stables of the WWE in the only
third-generation wrestling star in
history the story of Dwayne Johnson the
rock is a tale of dedication grit and
old-fashioned hard work in this week's
biographic s-- we chart the rise and the
rise of 2016 s sexiest man alive
Dwayne Johnson Dwayne Douglas Johnson
was born on May the 2nd 1972 in Hayward
County California
his mother Atta was of samoan origin
while his father
Wade was a black Nova Scotian Wade
earned a living as a professional
wrestler under the name of rocky Johnson
to further entrench the wrestling gene
in his blood Dwayne's maternal
grandfather also had been a professional
wrestler promoted as high chief Peter
Maivia
he was the first Samoan wrestler to
break into the big-time a generation
later rocky became the first black
champion to conquer the state wrestling
scene rocky hustled as a wrestler taking
on bouts wherever he could in order to
support his family times were tough with
the family moving from state to state in
order to keep pace with the wrestling
venues in fact during Dwayne's formative
years the family of three lived in 38 of
the 50 states as they became entrenched
in the Gipsy wrestling lifestyle
the only time Dwayne got to see his dad
was when he went on the road with him he
cherished these times and quickly fell
in love with everything to do with
professional wrestling his dad taught
him some basic moves including the
sleeper hold when he was 11 Dwayne was
playing wrestling one school lunchtime
when he put the sleeper hold on a
classmate the kid immediately passed out
unfortunately rocky hadn't shown his son
how to bring someone out of the sleeper
hold the ambulance and the police were
called and rocky had to come down to
revive the students the Johnson house
became a hangout for Dwayne's
schoolmates who knew that they were
going to have to do several round
with their host Dwayne would turn these
events into mock TV shows where he would
pretend to interview the Restless he
would even interview himself as he
portrayed the bad guy his chairmanship
was immediately evidence as he came out
with all sorts of outrageous
pronouncements against his intended
victims Dwayne excelled in a number of
sports physically he was miles ahead of
his classmates he had his first weight
workouts when he was 13 but he'd been
tagging along with his dad to the gym
since he was 5 years old as he sat
quietly on a bench and watched proudly
as rocky pounded out set after set with
gargantuan weights Dwayne breathed in
the gym atmosphere and marveled at the
sight of huge men doing seemingly
impossible things with massive loads of
iron while other dance took their kids
to the playground rocky took Dwayne to
most of the hardcore gyms in the country
it was here that the future superstar
learns that there was no replacement for
pure gut-wrenching hard work at the age
of 8 rocky allowed Dwayne to participate
in sports
he tried baseball soccer martial arts
and gymnastics what he really longed to
do was lift weights but it'd have to
wait a few more years to get into that
finally on his 13th birthday his dad
took him to a local gym for his first
ever weights workout an obvious place to
start was the bench press which had
studied for years as his dad and others
pressed massive amounts of Steel from
their chests rocky had his son start
with an unloaded bar he pumped out 10
reps with no problem so rocky added a 20
pounds plate to each ends this time
Dwayne pushed out eight easy reps
impressed rocky asked his son if he
wanted to try the 45 pounders Dwayne not
at his head his dad stood behind him and
lifted the bar off the supports and
Dwayne got buried under the 135 pound
weight he felt embarrassed and ashamed
as if he had let his dad down that
feeling fueled an intense desire to get
better at the benchpress and within a
few years he would be benching 400
pounds between the ages of 14 and 15
Dwayne excelled in the gym by the time
you entered high school he had grown to
a towering 6-foot 3-inches and tipped
the scale at 225 pounds his imposing
physicality gave him a great
steel of self-confidence which sometimes
bordered on arrogance but his unstable
home life that saw his father constantly
traveling left him directionless when he
wasn't pounding the weights as a result
of this he started to get into trouble
it came to a head when he was 15 and he
got arrested for check fraud his parents
had to come and collect him from the
police station
when he looked at his mother and father
and he realized that despite living from
paycheck to paycheck he was the biggest
source of stress in their lives in that
moment he vowed that he would never
cause problem for his parents again
although that was the last time that
Dewayne got arrested it wasn't the last
time he caused worry for rocky Anita in
fact that very next day at school he got
into a fight and knocked the other kid
out it turns in a two-week suspension
upon returning to school he decided that
the students bathroom was not good
enough for him and so he decided to use
the teachers one when asked to leave he
was rude to the teacher and tried to
intimidate him with his physical
presence that night drain felt pangs of
guilt of the way he had treated the
teacher so the next day he marched in to
the teachers class and holding out his
hand said that he wanted to apologize
for the way he had acted the day before
the teacher stared at Duane's hand for a
moment and then grabs it and told Wayne
that he appreciated the apology then
still holding the boy's hand he said I
want you to play football for me
[Music]
football proved to be a positive outlet
for Dwayne's frustrations and
aggressions providing him with a renewed
sense of focus under the watchful eye of
coach Jody Swick he steadily improved
both as a student and as an athlete by
the time he was a high school senior he
was ranked as one of the top 10
defensive tackles in the country and was
offered a scholarship to the University
of Miami the number one college team in
the United States at Miami Dwayne's
combination of size strength and
athleticism coupled with his strong work
ethic made him a standout from the very
beginning practice was going great and
he was primed to be the only freshman on
the varsity team but then tragedy struck
on the last day of practice with pads he
crashed the grounds with his full weight
on his shoulder
it was dislocated and a number of
ligaments were torn that nights he had
reconstructive surgery and was told that
it need a year to recover he was not
able to play before the season had even
begun
Dwayne he fell into a deep depression
not even bothering to go to class then
without even attempting any of his
midterms he hopped on a flight and
returned home which at that time was in
Tampa Florida after a couple of weeks he
got a call from Miami's head coach
Dennis Erickson
he told Dwayne that he wanted him back
at school in two days because he wanted
to talk to him when they met up Erickson
was furious with Johnson he told him
that that he had embarrassed himself and
the team Erickson had trusted him with a
position of responsibility and
leadership and he had completely let him
down Erickson then placed Dwayne under
academic probation he was to attempt
every class every practice and every
game simply sitting on the sidelines
however to get it into daily practice he
had to get the signatures of every one
of his professors attesting that he had
been to class that day if he didn't it
would lose his scholarship Dwayne
dug deep and did what had to be done he
eventually became academic captain in
his junior year and was preseason
all-american he graduated from Miami
University in 1995 with a Bachelor of
general studies in criminology and
physiology it was at the University of
Miami the Dwyane first met Danny Garcia
his future wife they were married in
1997 and divorced ten years later after
a years injury recovery
Dwayne wasn't quite as fast or
mobile as he was on the football fields
he was taken from the team and replaced
by Warren Sapp after graduation from
Miami Dwayne went to Calgary Canada as a
practice squad player for the Stampeders
things were tough for him in Canada he
had hardly any money and very few
prospects but things got worse when he
was cut from the Stampeders squad after
just two months arriving back at his
parents tiny apartment in Tampa Dwayne
was now at rock bottom on his football
career was effectively over and he
needed to look in another direction he
thought deeply and realized that his
life and his passion had always been
professional wrestling if he never
turned his hand to it he would forever
be unfulfilled and if he was going to
step into that world well that was the
time his mother Aaron's girlfriend
encouraged him to go for it but Dwayne's
dad had major reservations rocky knew
firsthand just how tough the life of
wrestler was and he wanted more for his
son but he vowed to stand behind his son
so long as he put in 110% effort into
becoming successful rocky now became
Dwayne's full-time wrestling coach from
the start though he taught him much more
than simple wrestling moves he taught
him how to be a showman
after a few months of intensive work
rocky felt his son was ready to take the
next step he got in touch with a former
wrestler named Pat Patterson who was now
a talent agent Patterson came to check
out what Dwayne looks like in the ring
impressed he arranged for a signing with
the WWE Dwayne was put into the minor
leagues and was given the name Rocky
Maivia in homage to both his father and
his grandfather he started wrestling in
small arenas for $20 a pop but it didn't
take long before he got his break the
1996 WWE Survivor Series was televised
live on TV from Madison Square Garden
and the new kid on the block was Rocky
Maivia he made an immediate impression
establishing himself as a rising WWE
star by becoming the last man standing
Rocky Maivia took on a charismatic
in-your-face persona which proved to be
too loud and too arrogance for many
diehard WWE fans his character was
rejected for being too tacky and fans
came to see Rocky Maivia as an extremely
unlikable character when he wrestled the
stadium would be
with signs reading rocky sucks and die
rocky died but his perseverance and the
constant refining of his character
eventually won the fans over fans came
to appreciate the much of Rocky's
narcissism was tongue-in-cheek much in
the mold of Muhammad Ali and they began
to enjoy his over-the-top sense of humor
when he shortened his name to the rock
fans embraced it and within a year he
had transformed the wrestler everyone
loved to hate - the People's Champ
[Music]
throughout 1997 and 1998 the rock had
ongoing battles with Stone Cold Steve
Austin Triple H and mankind throughout
1999 the WWE championship belts passed
between the rock and mankind several
times during a series of epic encounters
then towards the end of 99 the two
teamed up to become the rock and sock
connection and went on to win the Tag
Team Championship three times the rock
and mankind also performed comedy skits
on WWE live telecasts one of them was a
take of this is your life in which
mankind interviewed people from the
Rock's past the segment drew in 8.4
Nielsen rating one of the highest ever
for a WWE segment in 2001 though the
rock was suspended indefinitely during
the airing of Raw is war he used the
suspension as an opportunity to move
into the action arena still he would
return again and again to the wrestling
ring in 2011 he was the host of
Wrestlemania he spent a large part of
the promo build-up insulting and
taunting John Cena who he had already
been calling out on social media a few
develops between the two which continued
for another two years
when he finally stepped away from the
wrestling ring in 2016 the rock had
established himself as one of the great
pro wrestlers of all time Hulk Hogan
himself a dominating WWE figure referred
to him as the biggest superstar in the
business a sentiment which was echoed by
John Cena one of his many catchphrases
lay the SmackDown inspired the title of
televisions second longest-running
series
Smackdown the rock is also entrenched
himself in the WWE record books
he was the first wrestler to win the WWF
WWE Championship seven times and it's
Intercontinental Championship reign of
265 days is the longest in the modern
era
[Music]
Duane's huge popularity as a WWE
character allowed him to cross over into
mainstream media his first acting job
was in a 1999 episode of that 70s show
in which he played his own father in
2000 he appeared in Star Trek Voyager as
an alien wrestler his first movie
appearance was a small role in 2001 The
Mummy Returns the movie was a smash hit
leading to a reprisal of this role this
time as the lead in the movie the
Scorpion King Johnson was paid 5.5
million dollars in that role earning in
a spot in the Guinness Book of Records
as the highest-paid actor in a debut
despite it actually being his second
movie this movie established Johnson is
a bona fide star with his comedy
credentials clearly established through
his wrestling career his next film the
action comedy the rundown was the
natural next step this was followed with
a remake movie walking tool this role
cemented Johnson's position as the
ultimate hard-as-nails action hero with
a heart of gold over the next few years
drain skipped between comedies and
action movies with such films as be cool
doom Tooth Fairy a film which was
originally written for one of the Rock's
heroes Arnold Schwarzenegger and The
Fast and the Furious his debut in The
Fast and the Furious came in the fifth
movie after fans demanded to see a
showdown between Johnson and Vin Diesel
the movie was the most successful in the
entire franchise making more than 86
million dollars on its opening weekend
this remains to this day the biggest
opening for any Johnson movie Dwayne has
in disbursed his movie roles with
appearances on a number of TV shows many
of them aimed at a preteen audience he
appeared in episodes of Corey in the
house and the Wizards of Waverly Place
and was the host of the Nickelodeon Kids
Choice Awards in 2009 that yet he also
appeared several times on Saturday Night
Live where he introduced his rock Obama
character and morphing of President
Obama with the Incredible Hulk
[Music]
by the end of the 2000s Johnson had
developed a reputation as a bankable
star who could not only carry a new
movie but also had a proven record of
being able to revive franchises that
were getting tired he became known as a
very busy actor with at least a couple
of new movies coming out each year in
2013 Johnson starred in a couple of true
life based movies pain and gain and
empire state he also announced that year
that he was to executive produce and
star in an HBO TV series set in the
world of professional football called
ballers in December of 2013 Forbes
magazine named Johnson as the
highest-paid actor of the year with
earnings of 1.3 billion dollars Bullas
which debuted on HBO in June of 2015
proved to be a huge success Johnson who
plays Spencer Strait more retired NFL
player who goes on to a career as a
financial planner for current NFL
players received props for his charm and
depth as of 2018 the show is in its
fourth season in 2014 Johnson played the
title character in Hercules for this
role he stepped up is already grueling
workout and nutrition protocol in order
to get as impressively muscular as
possible he followed this up with the
huge disaster hit san andreas before
switching back to comedy with Central
Intelligence alongside Kevin Hart 2016
saw Johnson teaming up with Zac Efron
for a feature movie version of the
classic beach and babes TV series
Baywatch the two hockey actors created a
lot of pre-release buzz with their epic
Beach workouts in which Johnson would
present Efron with gut-busting physical
challenges the movie however was a
box-office disappointment Johnson
finished out 2016 by learning that he
had been voted People magazine's sexiest
man alive the next big project was a
remake of the Robin Williams classic
Jumanji Johnson along with co-stars Jack
Black and Kevin Hart brought a new
updated angle to the story that
resonated with fans the movie has so far
brought in eight hundred and twenty-nine
million dollars on a 90 million dollar
budget
[Music]
throughout his life Dwayne has had one
constant that kept him grounded and
which he credits as the basis of
everything that he's achieved and that's
the gin from those earliest days when he
would sit and watch his father dominate
the weights in the 1970s the sights
smells and sounds of working out became
an integral part of his being Twain's
workout intensity and dedication have
been an inspiration to millions he hits
the gym at 4:00 a.m. every morning
training for up to two hours with heavy
basic compound moves in dispersed with
cardio to keep his body fat percentage
into the single digits he is also a
favorite in the bodybuilding community
appearing as a guest host at the 2016
mr. Olympia competition since 2014
Dwayne has been living in Southwest
Ranches in Florida his first child
Simone was born in 2001 while he was
still married to her mother Danny in
2015 his second daughter Jasmine was
born to his girlfriend of nine years
Lauren hash Ian Dwayne Johnson has risen
from humble beginnings to establish
himself as the most bankable movie star
of the 21st century in the process he
has brought back to mainstream
entertainment the sort of alpha male
persona that has been so absent for so
long he has become the people's champion
once again so I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographic if you did
there's a couple of things you could do
right now one is hit that like button
below also if you want more stuff like
this we put out brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday so hit that
subscribe button below and subscribe
button doesn't do what it used to on
YouTube if you actually want to get a
notification about these videos please
do hit that Bell button next to the
subscribe button and that'll send you a
notification every time every Monday and
Thursday won't put out a new video also
if you want to watch something else
right now stuff from the archive over
there on the right and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]